Donc les versets 26, ne cherchons pas une vainque gloire en nous provoquant les uns les autres, en nous portant en vie les uns les autres.
C'est un verset des transitions, c'est quelque part la conclusion de cette section du chapitre 5 où Paul nous porte l'enseignement sur ce qu'il veut dire des marchés selon l'esprit.
Et donc dans cette description l'apôtre Paul va utiliser plusieurs descriptions ou plusieurs perspectives différentes pour nous expliquer ce que cela signifie des marchés selon l'esprit.
Il faut qu'on se rappelle que l'objectif pratique de Paul c'est de régler une problématique très grave au sein de cette église.
Et par là, il a fait un glorieux travail pour nous équiper à comprendre une tension et la richesse et les distinctions d'un grand dilemme, d'un grand paradoxe théologique.
Donc les problèmes pratiques chez les Galaxes c'est que c'était une communauté convertie à partir des païens qui n'avaient aucune connaissance ou qui n'avaient pas beaucoup de connaissances envers l'arrière-plan juif de la foi chrétienne.
Et ils ont bien commencé leur carrière, c'est-à-dire qu'ils étaient véritablement convertis, ils sont devenus l'habitation de Saint-Esprit et ils étaient en train de commencer bien leur course.
Par contre, par l'interférence, par la présence, par l'arrivée d'un groupe de personnes qui étaient des chrétiens judaïsants, des chrétiens issus d'un arrière-plan juif,
mais pas que ça, des chrétiens qui, malgré la compréhension du besoin du Christ pour les saluts, pensaient que leur identité et la continuité de leurs pratiques religieuses
dépendaient encore beaucoup de la culture et des pratiques juives.
L'apôtre Paul, on sait très bien qu'il a bien saisi, bien compris la distinction entre l'ancienne alliance et la nouvelle alliance
et qu'il a compris en fait que pour plus que la compréhension de l'Ancien Testament enrichit notre compréhension de l'œuvre du Christ,
une fois que Christ vient pour remplir et tout accomplir, on n'a plus besoin de revenir à ces rapports obsolètes envers la suture, la pratique religieuse ou même la culture juive.
Par contre, les Galates, malgré un bon début, ils se sont laissés porter par ces mauvaises influences.
Et ils sont arrivés à un point où il y a eu une division au sein de cette Église.
Et cette division a eu lieu au moins par la définition, de manière assez générale, des trois groupes.
Un groupe qui était les judaïsants et ceux qui étaient sous leur influence, qui pensaient que, ok, on avait besoin du Christ pour être sauvés,
mais nous maintenons et nous progressons dans la foi et nous nous assurons de ne pas perdre cette condition privilégiée en tant qu'enfant des dieux,
si, après la conversion avec Christ, nous nous adaptons progressivement à la culture juive.
C'est-à-dire, Christ, qui a accompli parfaitement la loi à notre place et qui est mort à la croix pour souffrir la punition de nos péchés,
il était nécessaire pour que je puisse recevoir un juste pardon de Dieu.
C'est-à-dire, Dieu peut me pardonner et me déclarer juste, car lorsque je m'approche de Dieu, je ne m'approche pas de Dieu selon ma performance.
Je ne m'approche pas pour conquérir son pardon, mais je m'approche de Dieu en reconnaissant mon état pécheur, ma coupabilité.
Et je dis, Seigneur, je veux m'approcher de toi à travers Christ.
Je m'associe par la foi à Christ et j'ai dit à Dieu, voici mon représentant légal devant ton tribunal.
Il a vécu la vie parfaite à ma place, il est mort à cause de péché.
À partir de là, on a une position qui ne peut plus jamais changer, car il a été un représentant légal effectif.
Mon sauveur, associé à Christ.
Dans la théorie, même les judaïsins étaient d'accord.
Dans la pratique, l'emphase qu'ils ont mis à partir de là, c'est pour dire,
OK, on a été sauvé par l'œuvre du Christ qui était parfaite,
mais à partir de là, comment nous allons mener nos vies.
Et eux, ils sont revenus sur une base des relations avec Dieu,
qui était la base de la performance.
Les plus j'obéis, les plus je progresse en santé.
Les plus j'obéis la loi, les plus Dieu va me venir.
Et lorsque je me dépare, lorsque je fais face
à mes faiblesses, à mes rechutes, à mes péchés,
soit je vais faire le choix de devenir hypocrite,
de faire semblant que je suis un grand observateur de la loi,
soit je dois me convaincre,
je dois revenir aux manières de la loi
pour reconquérir l'amour de Dieu.
Donc, toutes ces transpirations,
la circoncision qu'il gardait encore,
garder certaines dates,
une base des relations avec Dieu qui était névrotique.
Un salut, yo-yo.
Je perds mon salut, j'ai réglé mon salut.
Car à la fin des comptes, ça dépend de ma performance.
Je n'ai pas les réponses absolues de savoir
que Dieu m'a adopté parfaitement
et Dieu est pour moi.
À chaque fois, j'ai doute vraiment si Dieu m'aime
et s'il va me bénir,
car dans ma tête, ça reste encore l'idée
que ça dépend de moi,
que ça dépend de ma performance.
Et donc, à partir de là,
cet ajout des poids, des poids
et des peines et des sacrifices,
une idée de Dieu contre nous, tout simplement.
Donc, ces premiers groupes étaient sous cette influence.
Les deuxièmes groupes étaient sous une autre influence.
Ils étaient tellement convaincus
que Christ avait accompli parfaitement l'œuvre
parfaite pour nous pardonner
et pour nous créditer son obéissance.
et eux, ils se disaient,
donc, peu importe la manière dont je vis.
Donc, si Christ a tout payé,
maintenant, je peux me plonger dans les péchés,
donner de l'espace à la chair.
Et ces groupes étaient aussi complètement erronés.
Et Satan aime bien nous conduire d'un extrême à l'autre.
Et donc, dans cette autre extrême,
l'apôtre Poel est en train de dire clairement
que lorsque nous sommes associés à Christ par la foi,
lorsqu'il devient notre représentant légal,
nous sommes véritablement réconciliés avec Dieu.
Sauf que cette réconciliation avec Dieu
n'est pas tout simplement une question légale
où Dieu va m'absoudre devant son tribunal
pour me donner cette autonomie pécheresse.
Non, la vraie liberté,
la liberté qui nous a archonchis
de la condamnation de péché,
c'est la liberté qui a changé notre nature
et qui nous a archonchis aussi
de la domination ou de la pollution du péché.
Et donc, pour tous ceux qui se sont unis
véritablement à Christ par la foi,
qui étaient véritablement répandus de leur péché
et qui ont déposé la foi en Jésus-Christ,
ils sont non seulement associés à Christ
de manière légale,
mais ils sont associés à Christ de manière vitale.
C'est une union d'expérience,
c'est une unité organique avec Christ.
Donc, cette emphase d'épaule,
c'est remarquer que là,
tu vas vivre au début.
Vous n'aviez pas besoin des menaces de la loi,
la peur de perdre le salut,
l'idée d'un Dieu contre vous
pour vous maintenir dans la pratique du bien,
dans les progrès de la sainteté.
C'était naturel pour vous
de suivre le Saint-Esprit
et cette association avec Jésus
vous conduisait naturellement
à vous sanctifier.
Donc, l'apôtre Paul,
il est en train de dire
c'est qu'il est par la foi seule en Jésus seul,
par contre,
par une foi qui ne vient jamais seule,
si elle est vraie.
Elle est toujours accompagnée
des progrès, des bonnes œuvres,
des sanctifications.
Ceux qui ont été adoptés légalement
en tant qu'enfants des dieux
sont devenus véritablement
des enfants des dieux
et donc auront un comportement similaire
à celui de son père.
Et un troisième groupe,
c'était les groupes qui étaient corrects
dans leur théorie,
corrects dans la doctrine.
Ce sont ceux qui ont compris
que la justification des dieux,
ok, c'est quoi la justification à nouveau,
elle a deux aspects.
Le premier, c'est Dieu qui me déclare juste
car Christ avec sa droiture
est en train de me couvrir,
légalement.
et à nouveau,
un autre aspect,
Dieu qui va me rendre progressivement juste
en conformité à Christ.
Donc, une question légale
et une question organique.
Nouvelle création,
habitation du Saint-Esprit.
Donc, eux,
ils ont compris cette explication
de l'apôtre Paul
et au sein de cette Église,
ils faisaient des efforts
pour restaurer cette Église
à cette compréhension
et avec toutes ses implications pratiques.
Sauf qu'apparemment,
selon les exhortations de l'apôtre Paul,
tous étaient en train de se mordre
et se dévorer au sein de cette Église.
chacun pensant avoir mieux compris la vérité.
L'apôtre Paul,
avec son autorité apostolique,
qui porte clairement
la compréhension doctrinaire correcte,
mais qui en train d'insister sur le fait
qu'il ne suffit pas,
si nous voulons vraiment redresser
nos frères et sœurs,
il ne suffit pas d'avoir
la bonne compréhension de la vérité,
mais il suffit,
il suffit,
il suffit de conduire
les personnes à se redresser
par un esprit de douceur,
d'humilité,
de patience,
par le même amour sacrificiel du Christ.
Une Église sera complètement inefficace
dans son zèle pour la vérité
si la manière dont on essaie
de défendre la vérité est charnelle
et remplie
de vaines gloires,
d'orgueil,
des manques,
des tacts,
délicatesse.
Soigner l'âme
comme Jésus nous a enseigné,
c'est presque comme soigner les yeux.
On ne peut pas essayer
d'enlever la poutre,
la paille des yeux
de nos frères et sœurs
si on a une poutre
devant nos yeux.
Et donc tous nivellés à plat
car tous étaient en train
de céder au reste
de ces instants charnels.
Tous étaient en train d'échouer
pour ce qui concerne
la vie
qui est caractérisée
par la marche dans le Saint-Esprit.
Et donc on a déjà considéré
quelles sont les œuvres de la chair
et marcher selon l'Esprit
signifie
d'être constamment
en train de crucifier
ces impulsions
charnelles.
Nous avons considéré
ce qui est la vraie vie
de vrai chrétien.
C'est cette vie
qui est de manière
très naturelle
sous l'influence
de son esprit
avec une nouvelle nature
va prédominamment
désirer
et avoir la capacité
effective
de marcher
dans la direction
du fruit de l'esprit.
Et on a considéré
ce qui est
les fruits de l'esprit.
Et Paul arrive
à cette conclusion
par les versets 23
à 25
en nous rappelant
que la loi
n'est pas
contre ces choses.
C'est-à-dire
les fruits de l'esprit
à la fin des comptes
il peut ne pas
avoir besoin
de cette loi
si détaillée
dans l'Ancien Testament
car la présence
du Saint-Esprit
en nous
c'est la présence
de celui qui était
l'inspiration
de la révélation
de la loi
et la loi
étant ou ayant
pour base fondamentale
les caractères
des dieux lui-même
si dieux lui-même
habite en moi
par son esprit
c'est clair
que ces influences
vont me conduire
envers une vie
qui sera
en conformité
envers les attentes
de la loi.
Si je suis plus concentré
à voir comment Christ
a vécu
dans la pratique
et si je suis plus concentré
à me laisser influencer
par le Saint-Esprit
je vais inévitablement
me conformer
aux attentes
de la loi
mêner cette vie d'amour.
Et donc
c'est pas pour dire
que la loi
est complètement
méprisable
au contraire
car Christ lui-même
va réaffirmer la loi
sauf qu'il lui-même
l'écrit
il devient
l'incarnation
de la loi
et nous donne
une compréhension
de la loi
beaucoup plus profonde
beaucoup plus large
beaucoup plus élevée.
C'est pas contrairement
à la loi
mais c'est
avec l'essence
ultime
de la loi
que nous voyons
cette chose
et donc
les fruits
de l'esprit
la présence
si nous marchons
dans l'esprit
nous accomplissons
la loi
et de la même
manière
à la rume
Paul est en train
de détruire
les deux
fausses extrêmes
l'égalisme
c'est pas la loi
qui va ma capacité
à l'accomplir
c'est Christ
et libertinage
le fait
que Christ
accomplit la loi
ne me jette pas
dans une condition
où je peux pécher
au contraire
naturellement
par la présence
de l'esprit
du Christ
je vais
accomplir
volontairement
la loi
et donc
il dit aussi
verset 24
ceux qui sont
Jésus Christ
ont crucifié
la chair
d'une manière
radicale
car on était
un Christ
par la fois
lorsqu'il a été
crucifié
avec ses passions
et désirs
donc les chrétiens
seront très attentifs
envers ses passions
et désirs
devant toutes les situations
lorsqu'on a été
offensé
mis en question
lorsqu'on a été
surpris par une faute
comment je vais
réagir
ok
et donc crucifier
la chair
les œuvres de la chair
et en même temps
si nous vivons
par l'esprit
verset 25
marchons aussi
sur l'esprit
donc tous ces passages
ayant pour but
de décrire
ce qui est la vie
dans l'esprit
et à nouveau
c'est une description
de ce qui nous sommes
si nous sommes convertis
mais c'est aussi
une exhortation
à manifester
ce qui nous sommes
si nous sommes convertis
et c'est important
car la manière
pour Paul
de redresser
cette église
avec tous ses problèmes
n'était pas
de leur donner
une nouvelle liste
de quoi faire
c'est de rappeler
ce qui nous sommes
les puissances
qui nous avons
à notre disposition
et l'exhortation
à manifester
les fruits de l'esprit
et il va conclure
cette section
en faisant
la transition
envers les applications
pratiques
et c'est ici
que j'ai mentionné
dans ma prière
que Paul
va faire cette transition
c'est par là
que nous apprenons aussi
à préparer les sermons
entre
l'explication
doctrinale
les vérités
qui nous concernent
et
les implications
pratiques
les exhortations
vers nous
et dans cette section
plusieurs théologiens
considèrent que
les versets 26
en tout cas
c'est un verset de transition
nous savons bien
que la numération
des versets
ne sont pas inspirés
c'est une organisation
humaine
et pour plusieurs
c'est plutôt
les premiers versets
de la prochaine section
en tout cas
c'est un verset de transition
car à partir de là
il devient très pratique
envers les problèmes
au sein de l'église
et donc c'est très important
pour nous
tout de suite
avant même d'avancer
de considérer
l'importance
pour nous
de ne pas être
des auditeurs
oublieux
des personnes
très intéressées
à la théologie
sans que nous ayons
la compréhension
de l'importance
et de la centralité
qu'au sein
de nos communautés
des églises
nous puissions
manifester
cet amour fraternel
car Christ a résumé
la loi en disant
je vous donne
un commandement nouveau
aimez-vous
les uns les autres
comme moi
je vous ai aimé
le seul aspect nouveau
de ces commandements
c'est comme moi
je vous ai aimé
par un amour
sacrificiel
d'alliance
par un amour
communautaire
et pourquoi
car c'est exactement
comme ça
que ceux de l'extérieur
reconnaîtront
que vous êtes
mes disciples
ils vont identifier
chez vous
habite
un type d'amour
qui est extraterrestre
pour les incroyants
qui va porter
les incroyants
à l'étonnement
par rapport
à la transformation
de nos vies
et notre manière
de traiter
nos fautes
nos problèmes
entre nous
de quelle manière
chaque individu
est prédisposé
à se sacrifier
à souffrir
les dommages
à porter
les fardeaux
de l'autre
afin de préserver
l'unité
de l'église
car c'est exactement
comme ça
que Christ
a ôté
nos fardeaux
et donc
la providence
des dieux
nous permet
de réfléchir
par rapport
à des situations
qui nous
nous
!
être en train
de vivre
au sein de l'église
car Satan
il aime beaucoup
comme j'ai mentionné
faire une tempête
sur une goutte d'eau
et c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
que lorsque la providence
nous permet
d'expérimenter
la réalité
des passages
bibliques
c'est encore
une preuve
du fait
que Dieu
est au travail
entre nous
et qu'il honore
la prédication
expositive
de la parole
de Dieu
des séries
de prédications
où
les prédicateurs
ne deviennent pas
les tyrans
ou l'autorité finale
pour choisir
le repas
de la communauté
c'est pas les pasteurs
qui vont devenir
quelque part
l'expert
dans les diagnostics
de la communauté
mais nous devenons
y compris les pasteurs
otages
du prochain verset
du prochain passage
et nous portons
tous les conseils
des dieux
ça peut sonner
très spirituel
pour certains
de dire
j'attends la révélation
du Saint-Esprit
par rapport
à ce que je vais prêcher
en même temps
nous voyons de manière
très claire
les exhortations
bibliques
et la méthode
biblique
de nous présenter
la vérité
par la cohérence
interne
des livres entiers
de la parole
des dieux
et Paul exhorte
à présenter
tous les conseils
des dieux
et donc
que la grâce
des dieux
puisse nous assister
pendant que nous
méditons sur ces textes
pour qu'on puisse
vivre dans la pratique
ces vérités
et donc ici
nous arrivons
à des applications
pratiques
de cette doctrine
sur
les œuvres de la chair
les fruits de l'esprit
dans la réalité
de l'unité
de l'Église
et ce qui est intéressant
de remarquer
c'est que l'apôtre Paul
par une sagesse
pastorale
et la sagesse
c'est celui
qu'il a inspiré
par rapport à la lettre
au texte biblique
le Saint-Esprit
elle ne nous donne pas
beaucoup
de détails
spécifiques
sur devant
quelles circonstances
spécifiques
nous sommes
et ça c'est très important
car parfois
certains pasteurs
sont tentés
à faire osage
du coup-pitte
comme une tranchière
et métrailler
la communauté
et parler
indirectement
en étant
assez explicite
et finir
pour humiller
les personnes
mais la réalité
c'est qu'il nous
semble devant
cette sagesse
ou même
lorsqu'il peut
il va corriger
par exemple
les Vaudis
ou Santic
il va mettre
plus d'emphase
sur les faits
qu'elles ont travaillé
ensemble
les biens
qu'elles ont fait
et on n'a pas
la conception exacte
de leur erreur
c'est clair
que ceux
de cette communauté
savaient très bien
à quoi
ils s'adressaient
mais c'est aussi
la sagesse
du Saint-Esprit
pour que
lorsque nous
prêchons
même les portions
exhortatives
de manière
suffisante
le Saint-Esprit
est encore
de la marge
pour appliquer
à chacun
d'entre nous
et par là
nous n'essaierons pas
en train de réduire
la capacité
de Saint-Esprit
en donnant
chaque fois
plus
d'exemples
d'applications
pratiques
et donc ici
nous voyons
de manière très claire
que Paul
va commencer
à diriger
des exhortations
qui illustrent
comment
les fruits
de l'Esprit
doivent surmonter
les œuvres
de la chair
au sein de cette Église
et donc
c'est des marchés
selon l'Esprit
selon la vérité
centrale
pour nous
aujourd'hui
c'est que
tous ceux
qui sont
en Christ
vivent
selon la loi
du Christ
et doivent
manifester
au sein
de la famille
des fois
les faits
qu'ils sont
sous la loi
du Christ
être
sous la loi
du Christ
c'est d'agir
comme Christ
pour plaire
Christ seul
ayant conscience
que ça doit
faire partir
de notre désir
le plus spontané
et naturel
car on a été
saisi par l'amour
du Christ
au moment
de la conversion
mais en nous rappelant
qu'il s'arrête
quand même
en dévoiure
ça veut dire
que je ne dois
pas attendre
que mes passions
ou mes désirs
charnels
soient apaisés
avant que je puisse
agir
c'est d'agir
dans cette direction
même si je dois
crucifier la chair
pour les faire
c'est d'être
sous
la loi
du Christ
et donc
cela va se retrouver
surtout
dans les versets
qui est clairement
les versets centrales
de ces passages
au verset 2
du chapitre 6
portez les fardeaux
les uns des autres
et vous accomplirez
ainsi
la loi
du Christ
et donc
c'est certainement
les coeurs
de cette section
toute orbite
autour
de cette déclaration
et c'est une espèce
de résumé
de la vie
de la nouvelle alliance
nous allons mieux
comprendre
ce que cela veut dire
mais bien sûr
comme Galate
c'est un texte
où plusieurs
se rapporte
envers la loi
de Moïse
de manière
renée
il y a une emphase
et un contraste
envers
quel rapport
nous devons avoir
envers la loi
des dieux
et la réalité
c'est qu'au coeur
de ce passage
c'est qu'accomplir
la loi du Christ
rester avec moi
avoir avec
ses commandements
d'aimer les uns
les autres
comme il nous a aimés
les résumés
de la loi
selon lui
mais par la manière
particulière
et suprême
dont il a manifesté
cet amour
voilà pourquoi
porter les fardeaux
les uns des autres
il a porté notre croix
et par là
Paul va manifester
cette arme
puissante
pour détruire
les libertants
les judaïsants
et
pour désarmer
l'orgueil
et la vain gloire
même de ceux
qui étaient corrects
afin de redresser
toute la communauté
avec efficacité
et donc
tous ceux qui sont
en Christ
sont remplis
de son esprit
et donc doivent
accomplir
la loi du Christ
et donc
pour nous
ça va servir
à nouveau
des tests
d'évaluation
par rapport
à l'authenticité
de notre foi
mais aussi
en tant qu'impérative
pour vivre
de cette manière
et la question
qu'on va poser
à ces passages
c'est
de quelle manière
devons-nous
accomplir
la loi du Christ
selon ces passages
et donc la première réponse
et encore dans les versets 26
c'est que
d'accomplir
la loi du Christ
c'est de nous voir
par la perspective
du Christ
avec la précision
avec laquelle
Christ nous voit
c'est d'avoir
une perception
précise
de nous-mêmes
pourquoi
car ce qui conduit
le plus souvent
à la division
à l'église
ce qui conduit
aux provocations
et à l'envie
ce qui nous empêche
de nous corriger
et avoir un zèle
pour l'unité
c'est notamment
une perception
plus élevée
de nous-mêmes
par rapport
à nos frères et sœurs
et donc verset 26
ne cherchons pas
une vaine gloire
dans les littérales
mais dévenons pas
vides
des gloires
en nous provoquant
les uns les autres
donc comment nous pouvons
devenir
vides
des gloires
par une provocation
les uns vers les autres
pourquoi
car très souvent
lorsqu'ils nous cherchons
à nous promouvoir
à nous affirmer
devant nous-mêmes
et nous affirmer
devant la communauté
!
nous aimons bien
exposer nos frères et sœurs
à l'humiliation
diminuer les autres
pour nous considérer
plus élevés
promouvoir des débats
non par un intérêt
réel parfois
de conduire
l'interlocuteur
à la conversion
à la répentance
mais plutôt
exposer
combien nous connaissons
combien nous avons raison
!
par rapport à la manière
habile
dont on a pu
collecter les informations
nous présenter
comme très cultivés
vingt gloires
une gloire vide
car même si
ces mesures
de gloire
peuvent être
considérées parfois
par les mondes
comme des mesures
légitimes
d'appréciation
des crédentiels
d'importance
nous savons
que lorsque nous
mettons
toutes ces choses
en contraste
avec Christ
et ses attentes
envers nous
non seulement
par rapport
à combien brillant
on peut être
et par rapport
à notre
spiritualité
notre piété
notre capacité
d'aimer les prochains
d'avoir la compassion
de souffrir
les dommages
quelle est
la règle
qui mesure
ce qui devrait être
honorable
pour nous
les chrétiens
est-ce que
ce sont
ces mêmes règles
que les mondes
utilisent
capacité intellectuelle
position sociale
niveau d'instruction
combien pourrions
nous créditer
les brillantismes
que nous sommes
aujourd'hui
selon les mondes
à nous-mêmes
si nous savons
qu'à plusieurs égards
on a eu
des opportunités
beaucoup plus
privilégiées
que les autres
et comment nous assurer
!
que devant
le jugement
divin
un frère
ou une soeur
qui sont
beaucoup plus
simples
dans leur capacité
de défendre
leur position
théologique
dans leur capacité
d'expliquer
les textes
difficiles
comment nous assurer
qu'ils n'ont pas
une capacité
d'aimer Christ
plus grande
que la nôtre
d'aimer les prochains
d'être plus
humble
vaine gloire
avoir une perception
hypertrophiée
de nous-mêmes
surestimer
à nous-mêmes
!
et en même temps
utiliser des règles
pour nos pensées
importants
qui de soi-même
sont des gloires
vaines
donc
l'apôtre Paul
il n'a pas perdu
toutes ses conquêtes
au niveau
humain
le fait
qu'il soit
brillant
a été
ressignifié
utilisé
pour la gloire
des dieux
mais il a
connu
un moment
de sa vie
où malgré
toute sa connaissance
toute sa préparation
tous ses privilèges
par rapport
à son histoire
tout son niveau
d'éducation
ont été considérés
par eux-mêmes
comme des laboués
comme des labous
par eux
devant Christ
et donc
c'est quoi
véritablement
de ne pas chercher
une vaine gloire
c'est de nous rappeler
que ceux qui cherchent
les vaines gloires
cherchent
à se mesurer
par des critères
vains
ont une perception
surestimée
d'eux-mêmes
et ils manifestent
ces désirs
attention
ils manifestent
les désirs
d'être quelqu'un
d'important
par la polémique
par la provocation
ça peut
donner l'impression
qu'il est intéressé
à la sainteté
de cette personne
mais en vérité
il est plutôt en train
de vouloir exposer
ses fautes
pour se sentir
plus important
il est provocatif
dans ses échanges
toujours intéressé
au prochain
débat théologique
mais pas
très intéressé
à promouvoir
la piété
et la foi
nous portons
envie
les uns des autres
et ça peut
représenter
une espèce
d'atrophie
aussi par rapport
à ce que nous sommes
c'est-à-dire
d'avoir
une estime
de soi
qui soit très fragile
de ne pas être content
avec les lots
que Dieu a décidé
pour nous
et l'importance
que Dieu
crédite envers nous
car c'est lui-même
qui nous a placés
dans la position
spécifique
où nous sommes
dans les corps
et malgré parfois
en comparaison
avec nos autres
frères et sœurs
selon les critères
humains
on aurait pu
manquer
de quelques privilèges
ou de quelques
degrés
crédentiels
et par contre
par cette simplicité
c'est comme
John Owen disait
à propos
de John Boone
qu'il n'a qu'appris
à lire
pour savoir
comment lire la Bible
après sa conversion
qui était très simple
dans son éducation
et John Owen disait
qu'il changerait
toutes ses études
pour la piété
de John Boone
et qu'il disait
si on coupe
la peau de John Boone
c'est la Bible
qui sort
et donc
une position
atrophiée
une estime
envers nous-mêmes
mais ça peut aussi
sonner
la preuve
ou la manifestation
de combien
atrophiée
est la vue
de celui
qui pense être
très important
car c'est caractéristique
aussi de ces personnes
qui sont toujours
en train de se provoquer
ils sont toujours
en train de se disputer
dans leur tête
avec certains
dans la communauté
qu'ils peuvent
être gênés
par celui
qui est plus simple
que lui
mais en même temps
qui est très pieux
Paul a déjà
mis en phase
l'envie
que les judaïsants
avaient même
envers la liberté
des Galates
qui n'avaient pas
besoin
de toute cette
lourdeur
en termes
de vêtements
de méthode
de vie
une discipline
très rigide
mais pas
authentique
et donc
parfois
c'est une envie
qui s'y porte
envers même
ceux qui sont
plus simples
à leur égard
et qui montre
qu'en réalité
ils sont plutôt
dans les manques
que dans les débois
des manques
de l'autre côté
c'est intéressant
aussi de remarquer
que ça peut montrer
comment ils se sont
très fragilisés
à chaque fois
que quelqu'un
reçoit
de la part
des dieux
une certaine
éminence
au sein de la communauté
c'est l'incapacité
de se réjouir
avec les progrès
de l'évangile
à travers
la vie des autres
une tentation
à ne pas
vouloir
reconnaître
par exemple
des possibles
appels
au ministère
au sein de l'église
pour qu'il n'y ait pas
des ombres
par rapport
à mon ministère
n'est pas
appuyé
des ministères
qui sont conduits
par d'autres pasteurs
et même
dans la membreté
sans qu'on soit
en train de parler
des pasteurs
il y a aussi
cette envie
même dans les choses
les plus simples
si quelqu'un
va joindre une équipe
pour servir
dans une ère spécifique
si quelqu'un
commence à gagner
un peu plus d'espace
au lieu de nous réjouir
avec la mesure
des grâces
au lieu de nous contenter
avec la mesure
des grâces
qu'on a reçues
nous réjouir
avec la mesure
des grâces
qu'on identifie
chez les autres
on oublie
que nous sommes
tous membres
d'un propre corps
et que c'est
notamment par cette distribution
sage de la part
de Dieu
que nous allons
tous grandir
ensemble
c'est pour les bénéfices
de tous
et donc voilà
de quelle manière
cette vaine gloire
se manifeste
elle se manifeste
par l'envie
par la provocation
car quelque part
c'est apparemment
selon leur compréhension
la route
la plus courte
les mieux raccourcis
quelque part
pour être perçu
comme estimable
pour être en évidence
pour être dans l'évidence
d'être un agent
participatif
au sein de la communauté
qui semble vouloir
mettre toutes les choses
en règle
les chers champan
et la plus courte
les plus courte
portent en vie
les uns les autres
et donc comment régler
quelle est la solution
la solution
c'est de nous regarder
par la perspective
du Christ
on sait très bien
qu'il y a un moment
où on a été sauvé
si nous avons expérimenté
véritablement la conversion
voilà pourquoi on revient
au fruit de l'esprit
et aux béatitudes
les premières perceptions
de nous-mêmes
devant Dieu
car la vie vécue
avant la conversion
avant de nous approcher
des dieux
c'est une vie
qui veut échapper
et fouiller la présence
des dieux
et c'est une vie
des rois détrônés
ou détrônisés
je ne sais pas
comment on dit en français
qui sont toujours
à la recherche
ils n'ont pas
la conscience exacte
du fait
qu'on a été créé
à l'image des dieux
qu'on a perdu cette image
mais il y a encore
ces élans
cette soif
d'avoir
son appréciation
et sa valeur reconnue
et un élan
qui est très similaire
au premier péché
être traité
comme Dieu
et donc dans cette dynamique
avant la conversion
nous voulons
nous auto-promouvoir
et nous défendre
de manière exagérée
à tout instant
sauf que la conversion
est exactement
une perspective
de nous-mêmes
à la lumière
des dieux
dans sa gloire
et à la lumière
de ce qui nous sommes
comparativement
aux attentats de Dieu
envers nous
donc c'est d'avoir
une approche
envers Dieu
qui voit sa gloire
qui voit la beauté
de son caractère moral
de ses exigences
envers nous
une appréciation
énorme
envers ceux
qui ont des vrais êtres
et qui ont pourraient être
si les péchés
n'étaient pas là
et en même temps
qu'on a ces désirs
et cette aspiration
nous sommes contemplés
par la réalité
de ce qui nous sommes
sclaves du péché
de nos passions
charnelles
incapables d'aimer
de vivre une vie d'amour
envers nous-mêmes
avec cohérence
et envers les prochains
et donc
condamnés
par cette réalité
la Bible va décrire
que ceux qui sont
vraiment convertis
la première expérience
qu'ils ont eue
c'est la conscience
de leur pauvreté
spirituelle
ils ont vu
leur misère
non par une comparaison
avec les autres
mais leur misère
en se comparant
à Dieu
à Christ
j'ai des vrais
mais voir
comme Christ me voit
et de quelle manière
Christ me voit
il me voit
dans ma condition
misérable
d'abord et avant tout
voilà pourquoi
par condescendance
par compassion
par amour
il va
aller jusqu'à la croix
pour recevoir
les traitements
qui ont mérité souffrir
et donc les chrétiens
quand on voit
Christ crucifié
portant son fardeau
il dit
c'est moi
qui devrais être là
et c'est totalement
incohérent
avec ceux
qui ont un jour dit
c'est moi
qui devrais être là
des dévins
à chaque offense
chaque discute
sortir à sa propre défense
chercher à s'auto
promouvoir
complètement incohérent
avec l'évangile
c'est une hypertrophie
qui est complètement
vaine
c'est une gloire
totalement vaine
par contre
il y a cette misère
que nous devons avoir
conscience
pour toujours
car ce qu'on méritait
c'est ce qui Christ
avait que la croix
c'est l'enfer
mais Christ
nous a insérés
en lui
par sa grâce
par cette association
par la foi
et il nous a donné
des puissances
qui nous permettent
aujourd'hui
d'être beaucoup mieux
de ce qu'on était un jour
d'améliorer
de progresser
et ça doit
ajuster quelque part
la perception
que j'ai de moi-même
pas par mes mérites
mais oui
il y a un progrès
et oui
je vais persévérer
dans ces progrès
mais ça va m'empêcher
devant les membres
d'offense
de sortir
à ma propre défense
et donc
je dois être content
avec ma valeur
en Christ
et la position
que Christ m'a donnée
dans son corps
pas chercher
à désirer
des positions
tout simplement
car il me semble
plus estimable
plus visible
mais être sûr
d'être là
au poste
que Dieu a choisi
pour moi
et nous voyons
surtout
non seulement
que Christ
a restauré
ma valeur
en tant qu'image
de Dieu en lui
qu'il a révélé
quelle était ma valeur
dès moi-même
par mes efforts
et donc
il est en train
de tous niveler
à plat
mais il nous a laissé
aussi les paramètres
de comment
nous devons mener
nos relations
et donc
si l'humilité
pour nous
est tout simplement
cohérente
avec notre misérabilité
l'humilité
pour Christ
est une vertu
où il va
se dépouiller
de toute sa gloire
afin de nous retrouver
dans notre misère
afin de nous élever
en meilleure position
donc
Christ devient
pour les chrétiens
les modèles
ou les paramètres
de quelle manière
nous devons constamment
nous dépouiller
constamment
de cette notion
des droits
qu'on pourrait réclamer
de sortir
à notre propre défense
mais de démontrer
que nous ne sommes pas
vides
par rapport
à la perception
que nous avons
de nous-mêmes
mais qui nous sommes
tellement enrichis
et satisfaits
du fait
que Christ
nous a placés
avec lui
dans les régions célestes
avec toutes les bénédictions
pour toujours
et démontrer
la richesse spirituelle
de notre nouvelle nature
par la libéralité
la générosité
l'endurance
la patience
la douceur
devant toute occasion
des conflits
au sein de l'Église
celui qui se montre
vide
vent
une perception
personnelle
d'hypertrophie
mais
dans la pratique
par ses provocations
ses ailes sévères
démesurées
montrent
qu'il est en fait
atrophié
qu'il n'a pas compris
vraiment sa valeur
en Christ
car il n'arrive pas
à manifester Christ
dans sa vie
malgré sa précision
doctrinaire parfois
malgré sa diligence
son organisation
son désir
de faire fonctionner
l'ordre
au sein de l'Église
et tous
tous les groupes
peuvent se trouver
dans cette situation
c'est aussi important
de remarquer
le prochain point
accomplir la loi du Christ
c'est d'éveiller
comme Christ
pour nos frères et sœurs
donc cet équilibre
il montre
de manière très claire
que si d'un côté
on n'arrivera pas
à conduire
l'Église
ou préserver l'unité
ou redresser
l'Église
pour plus correct
dans la doctrine
qu'en soi
par un esprit
d'investigation
moraliste
les policiers
de la foi
les juges
de la sainteté
si ce n'est pas
par les voies
de la chair
qu'on va établir
la vérité
c'est notamment
par les fruits
de l'esprit
qu'on va surmonter
ces manifestations
de la chair
entre nous
donc l'apôtre Paul
il commence en disant
frère
et donc la répétition
des frères ici
nous rappelle
non seulement
l'affection
familiale
réelle
entre les membres
d'une Église
mais ça montre aussi
l'empressement
de l'apôtre Paul
a gardé
cette dynamique
d'exhortation
directe
personnelle
vous n'êtes pas
en train d'observer
tout simplement
un prédicateur
ce n'est pas
tout simplement
une lettre
impersonnelle
c'est un Paul
qui connaissait
personnellement
les personnes
à qui il s'adresse
et qui avait connaissance
de certaines circonstances
et donc
vous n'avez
jamais
cette fausse
conception
ou ces privilèges
de penser
que vous êtes
qui des auditeurs
quand vous êtes
devant une prédication
véritable
biblique
c'est toujours
Dieu
qui est en train
de vous interpeller
directement
à travers
les prédicateurs
donc frère
si un homme
vient à être
surpris
donc ici
c'est une note
aussi très intéressante
très pastorale
car nous ne sommes
pas devant
les manifestations
des péchés
qui sont prémédités
et récourantes
donc la Bible
elle est claire
par rapport
aux nuances
des traitements
sur certains péchés
donc si c'est quelque chose
de récourant
prémédité
il y aura un traitement
plus sévère
car là
on est déjà
devant les risques
d'être devant une personne
qui est un imposteur
par contre ici
c'est la considération
d'être devant
des frères et sœurs
qui ont été surpris
par un péché
par une mauvaise procédure
par
un décalage
ou
tomber à côté
littéralement
du schéma
de manquer les pas
car
avant
il avait parlé
des marchés
selon les pas
du Saint-Esprit
et maintenant
il est en train de parler
des personnes
qui sont sorties
de ces cas
il faut
revenir à l'esprit
les fruits de l'esprit
qui se concentrent
beaucoup plus
sur la manifestation
d'un caractère
équilibré
symétrique
doux patient
qui a un vrai zèle
pour la vérité
mais qui manifeste
cette quête
d'une manière
très douce
très chrétienne
et donc
il a été surpris
par exemple
une occasion bête
se passe
lorsqu'on est en train
de servir
et nous-mêmes
on s'est surprend
de la manière
dont on a réagi
et d'autres
peut-être
ont remarqué ça
donc
si un homme
et là
bien sûr
que ça veut
représenter
un individu
au sein de la communauté
ça s'applique
bien sûr
aux femmes aussi
vient à être
surpris
en quelques fautes
ok
donc
à qui
la responsabilité
de régler
ces problèmes
donc il y a
les démarches
les Matthieu 18
c'est d'abord
celui
à qui
plus à la providence
divine
de témoigner
les faits
il n'y a pas
une classe spéciale
dans son église
qui doit traiter
ces choses
toujours
bien sûr
qu'il y aura
des personnes
plus sensibles
à ça
plus douloure
c'est un rôle
particulier aussi
des diacres
d'avoir un zèle
général pour l'unité
d'église
pour la réconciliation
mais ni
tous les épisodes
des divisions
des chutes
sont
de la responsabilité
exclusive
aux primaires
des pasteurs
c'est
mon prochain
ici c'est un écho
des jeunesses
lorsque
Caïn va tuer Abel
et que Dieu
va poser cette question
où est
Abel ton frère
et sa réaction
suis-je
les gardiens
de mon frère
quelle est la réponse
oui
nous sommes
les gardiens
de mon frère
nous ne sommes pas
les investigateurs
de la foi
nous ne sommes pas
désireux
d'être reconnus
au sein de la communauté
comme ceux qui sont là
pour régler tous les problèmes
très intéressés
à savoir tout ce qui se passe
car il y a beaucoup
de risques
et des tentations
là aussi
et ici c'est un réproche
assez important
car si d'un côté
certains d'entre nous
sont tentés
très vite
à être très durs
et sévères
envers les fautes
au sein de la communauté
de l'autre côté
je pense que la majorité
d'entre nous
surtout
dans la peu de modernité
veut plutôt respecter
l'idolâtrie
de la privacité
et de ne pas interférer
ou nous insérer trop
dans la vie de personne
et donc cette négligence
je pense qu'elle est
en train de régner
dans la plupart
des églises de nos jours
où les relations
sont très superficielles
entre les membres
et on ne se sent pas
dans les droits
de manifester
un vrai amour
un vrai zèle
lorsque nos frères et sœurs
sont en train
de manifester
des pas
qui sortent
de l'harmonie
avec l'échément
de Saint-Esprit
ils sont en train
de manquer
la manifestation
du fruit de l'Esprit
ils sont en train
de prendre
une route
dangereuse
qui va tâcher
la réputation
des dieux
sur elle
et qui va
la mettre
dans une position
de plusieurs menaces
et donc
si quelqu'un
est surpris
en quelques fautes
ces fautes
peuvent être
des niveaux
doctrinaires
des comportements
des niveaux
des affections
et si
on a eu
la perception
c'est à nous
de venir
chercher
à régler
très intéressant
on a plus
d'exhortations
dans ces versets
qui se dirigent
à la responsabilité
et la manière
dont nous
devons chercher
à redresser
nos fers
et soeurs
qui est par rapport
au péché commis
ça c'est très important
car par rapport
à la pratique
de la réconciliation
il y a un critère
ici
qui est très important
c'est lui
qui cherchera
attention
à manifester
les ailes
pour la bonne santé
spirituelle
de l'église
et pour l'unité
n'est pas forcément
celui qui a été
qui a commis
l'offense
c'est tout simplement
celui
qui est
plus
résolu
à marcher
selon l'esprit
à manifester
les fruits
de l'esprit
vous êtes avec moi
si quelqu'un
a quelque chose
est contre toi
c'est pas toi
qui a quelque chose
contre quelqu'un
laisse ton offrande
et va régler les choses
pourquoi?
il dit
vous qui êtes spirituel
il n'est pas en train
de s'adresser
à un groupe spécifique
plus spirituel
que d'autres
dans la communauté
c'est toute l'emphase
des galates
vous avez reçu l'esprit
vous pouvez manifester
les fruits de l'esprit
vous êtes spirituel
vous êtes né de nouveau
vous êtes habitation
du Saint-Esprit
donc
ayez
ces désirs
déterminés
de redresser
celui qui chute
donc c'est très intéressant
ce que Calvin va dire
il va dire que
l'hypocrisie
de ceux qui sont
très sévères
pour corriger les autres
c'est notamment par là
qu'il affiche
que leur intérêt
n'est pas
de redresser
les frères
s'ils avaient
!
les mêmes désirs
pour redresser
les frères
qu'ils ont
pour saisir
cette occasion
pour s'autopromouvoir
ils agiraient
différemment
vers leurs frères
et sœurs
avec compassion
avec douceur
donc vous
qui êtes spirituel
redresser
c'est l'objectif
de toute correction
c'est de redresser
moi j'ai pu
manquer quelque chose
dans cette affaire
je serai les premiers
à être prédisposé
à confesser
mes fautes
même si mes fautes
comparativement
aux siennes
sont moins importantes
si j'ai 10%
des coupabilités
dans cette affaire
c'est lui
qui a plus rempli
le Saint-Esprit
c'est les premiers
à marcher
dans la direction
de la réconciliation
pourquoi?
car les paramètres
sont Christ
et Christ n'a jamais
eu aucune faute
par rapport
à nos fautes
mais c'est lui
le premier
qui va se dépouiller
de toute sa gloire
qui va abandonner
tous ses droits
qu'il aurait pu réclamer
pour souffrir
jusqu'à la croix
à cause de nos péchés
pour nous enlever
de cette condition
donc vous qui êtes
spirituel
redressez-le
avec un esprit
de douceur
il n'y a aucun autre esprit
qui soit cohérent
avec les chrétiens
lorsqu'il est devant
une faute
qu'elle soit la saine
ou celle d'un autre
c'est la solidarité
dans les péchés
qui nous unit
je me rappelle très bien
une fois qu'on est allé
faire un travail
dans les pénitentiaires
à Rio
et j'étais complètement brisé
car j'identifiais
un jeune
moi j'avais 18 ans
19 ans
et un jeune
qui venait d'être emprisonné
car il s'était mêlé
avec des drogues
des choses comme ça
et c'était des choses
qui par la grâce de Dieu
je ne pratiquais pas
mais toutes mes amitiés
pratiquaient avant ma conversion
et la conviction
que j'ai eu dans mon cœur
c'est que ça pourrait être
facilement moi
si j'étais juste
un petit peu plus susceptible
aux tentations
auxquelles j'étais
constamment exposé
c'est comme Augustin disait
je remercie à Dieu
non seulement
des péchés
qu'il me pardonne
mais aussi
des péchés
qu'il m'a empêché
de commettre
par sa pure grâce
voilà pourquoi il dit
avec un esprit
de douceur
car vous n'êtes rien
car
ça pourrait être
facilement vous
et plus que ça
quelque part
cet orgueil spirituel
de celui
qui n'est pas tombé
peut être plus pécheur
et dangereux
que celui
qui a échoué
qui a tombé
mais qui est véritablement
convaincu de son péché
même s'il n'a pas
toute la capacité
ou maturité encore
pour chercher
l'échirement
de la réconciliation
vous qui êtes spirituel
redressez-le
avec un esprit
de douceur
prends garde
à toi-même
des pères
que tu sois
aussi tenté
et donc là
c'est très important
il y a aussi
une exhortation
pour nos jours
car il y a
toute une vague nouvelle
envers les conseils
bibliques
et des conseils
pour organiser
les réunions
des groupes
des maisons
où nous voulons être
très encourageants
à un partage
à une vulnérabilité
qui devienne dangereuse
parfois
car Dieu
ne nous a tous
placés
à la position
des suprêmes
sacrificateurs
c'est des Christ
et nous n'avons pas
la capacité
comme Christ
il a
d'entendre
tous les problèmes
de toutes les personnes
sans nous contaminer
Christ il a cette capacité
nous non
à nous
d'entendre
les minimums
nécessaires
et chercher
à aider
avec une distance
de sécurité
n'est pas
traiter
de manière générale
des problèmes
personnels
certains peuvent être
en train de faire face
à certains problèmes
qui ne sont pas
les mêmes problèmes
pour toute la communauté
donc je n'ai pas
l'intérêt
à suivre
en série
d'études bibliques
contre la pornographie
car je sais
que ce n'est pas un problème
qui tous sont face
en même temps
certains ont déjà
surmonté les problèmes
et parler de ça
ne va faire
qu'égrandir les problèmes
Christ
dans sa beauté
dans sa gloire
dans sa suffisance
la piété positive
l'émerveillement
avec Christ
est beaucoup plus efficace
pour traiter
tous nos problèmes
et bien sûr
que si un frère
a été surpris
dans une faute
et qu'il a besoin
spécifique
dans ce point
dans ses cours
nous allons
pouvoir
la manière de l'aider
on ne sera pas
négligent
il n'y a pas d'espace
aussi pour la négligence
il faut qu'on soit
responsable
mais
avec la conscience
que nous devons être
humbles
pour savoir
que nous sommes
susceptibles
et vulnérables
de tomber
et que les péchés
a de soi-même
une puissance
contaminatrice
très forte
et donc là
des peurs
qui
tu ne sois
aussi tentés
donc c'est glorieux
de voir que
comment nous avons
la solution
pour ça
nous devons veiller
comme Christ
pour nos frères
et sœurs
dans le sens
où
Christ
est ce modèle
glorieux
de traiter
nos péchés
avec nos sœurs
comment il a traité
la femme
qui a été prise
dans la terre
va et ne pêche plus
mais
je ne te condamne pas
comment il a traité
la restauration
des pierres
qu'il a régné
trois fois
et Christ
qui va rassurer
qu'il lui-même
a la capacité
de les redresser
pour les ministères
c'est lui
qui est présenté
par Esaïe
et qui lui-même
va revenir
sur ses textes
en disant
qu'il ne brisera
pas les rouseaux
cassés
qu'il ne va pas
étendre la mèche
qu'il fume
mais qu'il va
quand même
annoncer la justice
selon la vérité
et la justice
est une justice
qui ne veut pas
imposer la vérité
mais qui veut nous conduire
par amour
à la vérité
avec la douceur
envers la justice
et envers la vérité
la correction
a beaucoup plus
d'efficacité
lorsque la personne
est encadrée
par l'amour
et l'espoir
des restaurations
que lorsque la voix
sonne plutôt
comme la voix
de Satan
comme une condamnation
une perte de salut
comme celle
d'un Dieu contre nous
si vous voulez
distinguer
la voix du Saint-Esprit
et la voix de Satan
c'est que
lorsque le Saint-Esprit
cherche à nous corriger
il nous donne
toujours de l'espoir
il nous motive
par sa prédisposition
à pardonner
à saisir l'occasion
et maximiser
sur la sanctification
c'est comme ça
que les hommes des dieux
et les femmes des dieux
rebondissent
sur leur occasion
des chutes
un pierre qui va
remonter
par une manière
beaucoup plus
glorieuse
dans sa manière
de conduire
son ministère
lui qui était
quelque part
assez
présomptueux
par rapport
à sa capacité
d'agir
par ses propres forces
donc c'est l'écrit
ce qui est
les modèles parfaits
il ne va pas briser
les roseaux cassés
donc si les personnes
sont déjà brisées
elles sont déjà répandues
à quoi bon
les maximiser
sur ces farlots
c'est lui
qui nous a enseigné
à traiter
de manière délicate
comme ces passages
de la poutre
et la paille
dont tu as déjà évoqué
et c'est surtout
ces modèles
du suprême sacrificateur
qui est le modèle
pour nous
de lorsque nous sommes
en train de traiter
les problèmes
de nos frères et sœurs
dans leur bataille
contre la tentation
contre le péché
devant les difficultés
de leur vie
qui parfois
les fragilisent
envers la tentation
et nous devons
chercher toujours
à garder ses cœurs
chercher à savoir
les minimums
qui est possible
et rappeler
à ces personnes
que même si nous sommes
là pour aider
nous ne pouvons pas
remplacer
les suprêmes
sacrificateurs
car Jésus Christ
est mort
ressuscité
il est à droite
du Père
et l'Abi nous dit
qu'il est compatissant
envers nous
car il a été
en tout tenté
sauf qu'il s'empêchait
donc nous devons
avoir la solidarité
car nous sommes aussi
en tout tentés
sauf qu'on a beaucoup
échoué
mais Christ
il a cette solidarité
envers nous
car il a vécu
cette vie parfaite
à notre place
et donc lui
il est là
en train d'intercéder
pour nous
donc nous devons
chercher
cet équilibre
cette symétrie
à ne pas
devenir
les inspecteurs
de la sainteté
communautaire
et en même temps
n'est pas négligé
lorsque la providence
nous permet
de croiser
un épisode
des péchés
nous devons
nous trouver
coincés
entre
la possibilité
d'échouer
que nous avons tous
et si nous avons
péché
nous devons être
prédisposés
à nous laisser
redresser
et être résolus
dans cette partie
du problème
à confesser
nos fautes
et chercher
la restauration
de l'autre côté
si on était
dans une position
où c'est plutôt
nous qui avons
témoigné la faute
nous devons être
encore peut-être
davantage vigilants
pour savoir
si la manière
dont on va conduire
cette restauration
ne nous mène pas
à une position
de péché
encore plus grave
et chercher
à conduire
avec douceur
cette révation
en tout cas
les modèles
sont toujours
le Christ
qui nous empêche
d'avoir
la vaine gloire
une vision
très élevée
de nous-mêmes
mais de l'autre côté
qui comme
il nous a placés
dans une position
glorieuse
en lui
par sa grâce
et par ses mérites
nous devons chercher
à restaurer
nos frères et soeurs
à cette même condition
nous allons prier
aujourd'hui
et laisser les prochains versets
pour la semaine prochaine
et la fin
on va